SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES- TO
ORDER A GOOD AFTERNOON
EVERYBODY I WANT TO TAKE A
MINUTE FIRST TO ANNOUNCE SOME
CHANGES TO OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERSHIP. AS YOU ALL KNOW WE-
BID FAREWELL TO SENATOR WILK- I
THINK IT WAS JUST LAST WEEK. I
AS HE STEPPED INTO THE ROLE OF
REPUBLICAN LEADER. AND SO HE
HAS THEREFORE LEFT THIS
COMMITTEE- SENATOR BATES WILL
BE TAKEN US SENATOR WIENER'S
WIENER SENATOR WILKES PLACE
JUST HAD A CONVERSATION.
SENATOR WORKS PLACES VICE CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE AND I KNOW
THEY WERE ALL EXCITED TO WORK
WITH HER IN THIS NEW CAPACITY
SO CONGRATULATIONS- SENATOR
BATES. FILLING THE VACANCY I'D
LIKE TO WELCOME RETURNING
MEMBER TO RULES- SENATOR GROWTH
SO I WANT TO SAY WELCOME BACK
WE'RE THRILLED TO SEE YOU HERE.
ARE RETURNING TO THIS COMMITTEE
GREAT ADDITION AND- FOR THOSE
OF US WHO. ARE SERVED WITH
SENATOR- GROWTH BEFORE. SO LET
ME JUST ASK SENATOR BATES
CENTER GROVE WITH EITHER OF YOU
LIKE TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS AT
THIS POINT- SHE IS. OKAY I
GUESS THAT WOULD BE A NO FROM
SENATOR BATES DIOP SENATOR
GROVE WELCOME THANK YOU I'M M.
MADAM PRETEND I JUST LIKE TO
THANK YOU GUYS FOR ALLOWING ME
TO RETURN TO RULES AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU. OUT WE DO AS WELL SENATOR.
SO WITH THAT I WILL GET BACK TO.
HOW WE START THE COMMITTEE I'M
GONNA MAKE SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE PROCESSES THAT WE'VE
DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
ESSENTIAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND OF COURSE FOR
THOSE OF YOU FAMILIAR. WITH
THIS PROCESS WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE WHILE I GO THROUGH IT
AGAIN FOR THOSE TUNING IN FOR
THE FIRST TIME. I WANT TO COVER
THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS
FOR THE DAY IN RESPONSE TO
COBIT NINETEEN IN THE EMERGENCY
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
SENATORS AND SENATE STAFF WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. IN COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE AND LOCAL ORDERS THE
SENATE WILL BE HOLDING THIS
ESSENTIAL HEARING HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO
OUR LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. BY
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC AND OUR
EMPLOYEES. WERE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH ONE OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WELL CENTER
BASE IS NOT WITH US TODAY SO WE
WILL HAVE NO ONE OF
PARTICIPATING NO MEMBER
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY.
AS IT RELATES TO OUR HEARING
PROCESS- WE WILL AND IN ORDER
TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS. WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. WE WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFIED TODAY AS WELL. AND
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THERE
IS A PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AND AN ACCESS CODE. IT'S
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AND IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR.
THE ACCESS CODE IS NINE TWO
FOUR ONE FOUR FIVE EIGHT. I'LL
REPEAT THAT AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME AS WE MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM. SO WHEN
WE DO MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT A
MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY WILL OPEN YOUR
LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THIS COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST DELETE THE
DEVICE THAT YOU ARE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
YOUR TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
OTHERWISE IT WILL CREATE- AN
ECHO SOUND AND WE WON'T BE ABLE
TO HEAR YOU AND WE WANT TO HEAR
FROM YOU SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PATIENCE AND YOU'RE- DOING THAT.
I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE ARE
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS ADJUSTING TO OUR
NEW ONLINE TOOLS. SO BE
PATIENT- I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE IS HEARD. ALSO
LET ME JUST ASK ON BEHALF OF
OUR STENOGRAPHER AINA. ALL
SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES ALIKE SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY. IF I HAVE TO
REMIND YOU TO SLOW DOWN I WILL
NO DISRESPECT INTENDED WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE CAPTURE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. SO ARE WE WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
PLEASE TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES.
HERTZBERG YOUR HERTZBERG HERE
GROW HERE ROLE HERE LAYARD HERE
LAYERED HERE ATKINS HERE ATKINS
HERE THANK YOU AND- FOR THE
RECORD- WE HAVE- ONE ITEM
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES REQUIRED
TO APPEAR ITEM ONE B. MICHAEL
YOUNGER DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
LABOR AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
AGENCY WILL BE HELD OVER FROM
THIS MEETING- AND- INCLUDED I
BELIEVE IN THE NEXT BUT IT WILL
BE NOTICED APPROPRIATELY BUT
THAT WILL NOT BE PART OF
TODAY'S AGENDA. I HAVEN'T SAID
THAT I WOULD ASK MY COLLEAGUES
MEMBERS TO ENTERTAIN MAYBE-
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO PUT- TO
DISPENSE WITH TAKE A MOTION ON
ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR THAT WOULD
BE ITEM TO SEE SOMEONE THANK
YOU THAT IS JOSEPH CURRENT
MEMBER OF THE WATER QUALITY
CONTROL BOARD THE SANTA. ANA
REGION. BOB LET'S GO AHEAD AND
VOTE ON THAT AND THEN I'LL TAKE
IT SUBSEQUENT MOTION ON THE
BILL OF FOR ALL. MAN SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL. HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG AYE GROWTH HIGH ROOF
I LAYERED HI THERE I ATKINS HI
ATKINS I OR ZERO THANK YOU THAT
IS FOUR TWO ZERO- AN ITEM
NUMBER THREE BILL REFERRALS
REFERENCE TO BILLS TO
COMMITTEE. APPROVED THANK YOU
MR MAJORITY LEADER. I AM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
HERTZBERG HE AYE HERTZBERG AYE
GROVE AYE ROVE AYE LAYERED AYE
AYE ATKINS HI RECONCILING THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES NOW WE WILL GO
TO OUR FIRST GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE REQUIRED TO APPEAR
THIS IS ITEM ONE A. AND IT'S
MISS KATRINA S. HAGEN ART
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS SO LET ME
SAY WELCOME DIRECTOR HAGEN IF
YOU WANT TO INTRODUCE YOURSELF
ANYONE THAT MIGHT BE WITH YOU
MAKE OPENING COMMENTS- THEN WE
WILL GO RIGHT TO MEMBERS SO LET
ME JUST SAY WELCOME AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AS WE GET
UNDER WAY. I THINK YOU FIVE CAN
YOU HEAR ME OK. YES WE CAN
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
TODAY I'M AYE I DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE WITH ME TODAY- THEY'RE
ALL DISTANCE LEARNING
DOWNSTAIRS- MY HUSBAND IS ALSO
LOGGED INTO WORK- SO IT'S AT
JUST ME I'M HIDING OUT IN MY
PANDEMIC OFFICE- AND WITH THAT
I'LL GO AHEAD AND JUST HAVE A
FEW OPENING COMMENTS- GOOD
AFTERNOON AGAIN. MADAM CHAIR
AND SENATORS LIKE MILLIONS OF
OTHERS ACROSS THE WORLD A YEAR
AGO I WAS RAPIDLY WORKING TO
TRANSITION AND NEARLY 1100% OF
THE DEPARTMENT WORKFORCE. THE
NEARLY 1100% HELLO WORKFORCE AT
AN UNIMAGINABLE PACE. AS I
QUICKLY WORKED TO ASSIMILATE
INTO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS I WAS
WORKING TO FURTHER TRANSITION.
OUR OPERATIONS TO A SUSTAINABLE
MINIMAL IN PERSON OPERATION
WELL AT THE SAME TIME LEADING A
KEY ORGANIZATION PROVIDING
GUIDANCE TO CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYERS AND WORKERS. ON LEAVE
OPTIONS WORKERS COMPENSATION
AND WORKPLACE HEALTH AND SAFETY
PROTOCOLS. THEY ARE
RESPONSIBILITIES INCLUDE
ENSURING WORKERS KNOW THEIR
RIGHTS UNDER THE LAW THAT WE
TAKE APPROPRIATE ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS AS WELL. AND SERVING IN
IT YOU TO COULD TORIA ROLL FOR
INJURED WORKERS AND THOSE
WORKERS WHO HAVE FACED
RETALIATION OR WAIT STAFF. I
WISH TO LEAVE DIR IN ITS
EFFORTS TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
WORKERS AND TO ENSURE EMPLOYERS
HAVE THE GUIDANCE SPACEY. ARE
TAKING STEPS TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH AND SAFETYOF THEIR
WORKFORCE ARE INSURED DURING
WORKERS ARE FREE FROM
RETALIATION AND RECEIVE
ENTITLED WAGES AND BENEFITS. I
WANT TO LEAVE THE DEPARTMENT
BECAUSE THERE IS NO OTHER ROLE
THAT ALLOWS ME TO DO THIS
IMPORTANT WORK BUT I HAVE SPENT
MY CAREER ADDRESSING. ENSURING
WORKFORCE PROTECTIONS ARE
UPHELD WHILE BALANCING WORKER
AND EMPLOYER PERSPECTIVE. MY
TWENTY PLUS YEARS OF STATE
LEADERSHIP EXPERIENCE HAS
PREPARED ME TO LEAD DIR DURING
THIS UNPRECEDENTED TIME. I PLAN
TO DO THIS BY BALANCINGOUR
INTERNAL WORKFORCE NEEDS WITH
THAT OF THE WORK FORCE AND
EMPLOYERS WE SERVE AND
CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVING UPON
BOTH. SOME EXAMPLES OF THAT
BALANCE INCLUDE ENSURING
CALLOSUM CAN INVESTIGATE AND
ENSURE WORKPLACE STANDARDS.
FIRST WE MUST ENSURE OUR
STANDARDS ARE THE RIGHT ONES.
LISTEN TO OUR EMPLOYERS AND
WORKERS FEEDBACK WHILE APPLYING
APPROPRIATE OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH
STANDARDS. WE MUST COMMUNICATE
AND TRAIN EMPLOYERS AND WORKERS
ON THE RESULT IN STANDARD WE
MUST ENSURE THAT HELLO CHAU
WORKFORCE IS ADEQUATELY STAFFED
AND PROTECTED AND HAS THE TOOLS
IT NEEDS TO ENFORCE STANDARDS.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT THE
DIVISION OF LABOR STANDARDS CAN
INVESTIGATE RETALIATION AND
WAGE CLAIMS. CLAIMANTS CAN
COLLECT THEIR JUDGMENTS AND OUR
CLAIMS PROCESS IS ACCESSIBLE
AND EFFECTIVELY COMMUNICATED TO
THOSE MOST VULNERABLE WORKERS.
IT TOO MUST BE ADEQUATELY
STAFFED TRAINED AND STAFF NEED
APPROPRIATE TOOLS. WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THE DIVISION OF
WORKERS COMPENSATION CAN
ADJUDICATE WORKERS COMPENSATION
CLAIMS WITH APPROPRIATE
REGULATORY AUTHORITY ENSURE NO
SIGNIFICANT DELAYS THE INJURED
WORKERS BENEFIT. ALL OF THESE
MISSION FOCUSED ACTIVITIES ARE
UNDERWAY AND IN VARIOUS STAGES
AND OUR CORE GRADED WITHIN D.
I. **** STRATEGIC PLAN WHICH
WILL SERVE AS OUR ROAD MAP OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS. I WISH TO
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS BY THINKING
THE LEGISLATURE FOR THEIR
SUPPORT OF DIR WITH RECENT
BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS TO SUPPORT
MANY OF THE REFERENCED BOWLS. I
ALSO WISH TO THANK THE
INCREDIBLE TEAM MEMBERS OF DIR
WHO WORK TIRELESSLY TO PROTECT
WORKERS EVERY DAY THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THEIR UNFLAGGING
COMMITMENTS BASS XPERTISE AND
PROFESSIONALISM INSPIRES ME
EVERY DAY. I'M AVAILABLE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DIRECTOR LET ME- TURN
AND START WITH SENATOR LATER
TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
MAN PRO TEM. I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO MEET UP- MS
HAGEN AND- HELLO MORE
DISCUSSION AND SHEET METAL MY
QUESTIONS AND SHE HAS NO
OPPOSITION I FEEL NO NEED TO
PUT ANY OF THE QUESTIONS ON THE
RECORD AND I'M GOING TO BE VERY
PLEASED TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYERED ARE SENATOR
GROWTH. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT OR MADAM PRETEND IT
WAS DEFINITELY MY PLEASURE
SPEND SOMETIME WITH YOU THIS
MORNING DIRECTOR I REALLY
APPRECIATED THE CONVERSATION
THAT WE HAD I DO HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS AND- BEFORE I GO TO
THOSE I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
FOLLOWING UP OR SENDING ME AN
EMAIL THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
FOLLOW UP WITH MY RETROACTIVITY
QUESTION REGARDING. AN
PROPOSITION TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
FIVE AND WHOSE INCLUDED HIS
EXCLUDED AND THOSE KIND OF
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE HAD ON IT
THE RETROACTIVITY. I DO WE
DIDN'T HAVE TIME BECAUSE OF
THAT CONVERSATION TO GET INTO
SOME WORKERS COMP ISSUES- WE
GOT INTO A COUPLE BIT ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT I HAD ON
WORKERS COMP IS THAT I'M GLAD
THAT OSHA'S STEPPED UP AND MADE
SURE THAT DURING THE PANDEMIC
OR EMPLOYEES- ARE SAFE. BUT
THEY DID FELL TO HOLD ADVISORY
MEETINGS BEFORE ISSUING THE
COBRA TEMPORARY STANDARD AND I
WAS THEM I UNDERSTAND YOU
HAVING MEETINGS NOW YOU SAID
THAT THE LAST MEETING WAS TODAY
YOU'VE HAD CONSISTENT MEETINGS-
OVER THE LAST FEW DAYS. A FEW
WEEKS AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT
YOU'LL- TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE
BUSINESS CAN A COMMUNITY NEEDS
I WAS OUT WONDERING IF YOU ARE
GOING TO BE CONSIDERING KEEPING
THE RAKES TEMPORARY SINCE WE
HAVE EVER CHANGING DYNAMAT
DYNAMICS LIKE VACCINES CHANGES
TO THE IMPACT THE SPREAD- THE
DO YOU ANTICIPATE. THESE
REGULATIONS BECOMING PERMANENT.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION- IT
IS V. WE DID HAVE THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE MEETINGS- AFTER THE
EMERGENCY TEMPORARY STANDARD-
WAS PUT IN PLACE AND IN FACT
THEY STARTED LAST WEEK AND ARE
CONTINUING- THIS WEEK. AND UP
AT TODAY THEY CONCLUDE- IT.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THAT- THAT CADENCE OR THAT
PROCESS IS FAIRLY TYPICAL OF
THE RULE MAKING PROCESS. WE DID
HAVE- A NUMBER OF OPPORTUNITIES
FOR AT FEEDBACK- AT THE-
OVERSHADOWED THE STANDARDS
BOARD MEETINGS- IN THE FALL-
AND I ATTENDED THOSE MEETINGS
AS A MEMBER AT COMMUNITY
MEMBERS WHILE LISTENING TO ALL
THE EMPLOYER AND LABOR
FEEDBACK. AND WE TOOK AT ALL OF
THOSE COMMENTS HELLO SHE TOOK
ALL OF THOSE COMMENTS BACK- AND
MADE SURE THAT- WE DID OUR BEST
TO REFLECT. THE FEEDBACK- AND
BALANCE THE NEEDS TO PROTECT.
OUR WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA WITH
YOU KNOW THAT THE EMPLOYERS-
NEED TO BE ABLE TO CONDUCT AND
IT YOU KNOW THE VISION OF
BUSINESS OPERATIONS- SO WE DID
HAVE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
FEEDBACK- THE WE COMMENDED WHEN
IMPLEMENTING THE EMERGENCY
TEMPORARY STANDARD THAT WE
WOULD HAVE ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS BEFORE WE-
RENDERED THE PERMANENT-
STANDARD. AND SO AND THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT'S OCCURRING NOW- SO
TO YOUR QUESTION IT'S- WE DO
INTEND TO ISSUE PERMANENT
STANDARDS BUT WE DO RECOGNIZE.
THAT THINGS ARE CONSTANTLY
CHANGING- WITHIN YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT CDC GUIDANCE COMING
OUT- YOU KNOW ADDITIONAL
RESEARCH BEING DONE- AND IT'S
VERY POSSIBLE THAT. GOING
FORWARD WE MAY MODIFY- THAT THE
REGULATION- OR MAKE SOME SORT
OF- CHANGE TO THEM GOING
FORWARD. AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT I APPRECIATE
THAT- MY LAST QUESTION THAT I
HAVE IS M. S. B. EIGHT SIXTY
THREE WHICH I WAS ABLE TO TAKE
PART OF BROUGHT RELIEF TO
EMPLOYERS. AND GAIN GREATER
BENEFITS TO WORKERS UNDER THE
WORKERS COMP SYSTEM AND I WOULD
HOPE YOU CONTINUE TO ADDRESS
THE REGULATIONS INTHAT WAY- SO
THAT WE DON'T INCREASE COSTS TO
THE SYSTEM. SOME EXAMPLES ARE
LIKE YOU AND ME REPORTS COPY
SERVICES AND- THE SUBSEQUENT
BENEFIT INTRIGUED AND- THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS THEY REALLY-
THEY'VE- THEY'VE- THEY SHOULD
BE COMING DOWN. BASED ON THAT
THE PARAMETERS ARE SET WITH SB
EIGHT SIXTY THREE WE'RE I'M
HOPING TAT YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO REDUCE THOSE COSTS.
TO EMPLOYERS SO THAT GREATER
BENEFITS GO TO OUR EMPLOYEES.
YES THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AND AN ABSOLUTELY- ONE
OF THE- MAJOR GOALS THAT WE
HAVE OUTLINED IN OUR STRATEGIC
PLAN IS TO REALLY FOCUS ON
OPERATIONAL EFFICIENCIES I
THINK THAT IS OUR- BIGGEST
OPPORTUNITY TO. TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR COSTUMES GROW
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER TIME- WE ARE
ALSO TAKING A LOOK AT- THE SIP
T. F. B. U. ETF PROGRAMS TO SEE
IF THERE ARE. WAYS WE CAN
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE ODD
THROUGH THE REGULATORY PROCESS-
TO SORT OF STREAMLINED SOME OF
THOSE CLAIMS- AND ALSO. LOOKING
TO LEVERAGE THE POWER. BE AT
COMMISSION ON HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS CHEESE WICK- TO DO
SOME ADDITIONAL STUDY
SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR POINT ON
THAT COPY FEE SCHEDULES AND
THAT- THAT THAT LEGAL MED LEGAL
SCHEDULES- IF THERE WERE SOME
STUDIES DONE BACK IN
200-016-2000 SEVENTEEN TIME
FRAME. I'M I'VE LOOKED AT THOSE
A NIGHT I WOULD LIKE VERY MUCH
TO- APPROACH THE COMMISSION ON
POSSIBLY. TAKING ANOTHER LOOK
LOOK AT BEST PRACTICES- AROUND
THE COUNTRY AND SEE IF THERE'S
WAYS WE CAN. IMPROVE UPON THOSE
SO ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO. FROM ANY
NEW IDEAS IN THAT- BROWN- BUT
OVERALL WE ARE IN FACT LOOKING
AT WAYS TO. CONTINUOUSLY
OPERATIONS TO IMPROVE. AS A
COST SAVINGS MEASURE. THANK YOU
MA'AM AND YOU FOR THE- AGAIN
THAT WE HAVE THIS MORE MORE
AND- I LOOK FORWARD TO
SUPPORTING YOUR CONFIRMATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
GROVE ARE. SENATOR MR MAJORITY
LEADER GO HIT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I UNLIKE MY
DISTINGUISHED COLLEAGUES I
APOLOGIZE I DIDN'T GET THE TIME
AND- IT'D TO SPEND TIME WITH
YOU SO I'M SO SORRY THAT I JUST
GOT A COUPLE OF QUICK
ENQUIRIES. I WANT TO ASK ON THE
PUBLIC RECORD. THE FIRST ISSUE
IS ON. FROM HOME WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE- THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTE RURAL STUDIES OF
PROGRAM WHICH LOOKED AT AT
FARMWORKERS AND HOW THEY FEEL
ABOUT THEIR WORKPLACE HEALTH
AND SAFETY ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
EIGHT YEARS GLORIA ALONG STATUS
STATEMENT IN THAT REGARD
THERE'S A SENTIMENT THAT IT'S
INEFFECTIVE AND UNPRODUCTIVE
THERE'S AN ISSUE ABOUT CAL
OSHA'S EMPLOYERS HAVING DENIED
MASKS PAID SICK LEAVE AND
REFUSED TO ENACT PUBLIC SAFETY
GUIDELINES LIKE SOCIAL
DISTANCING FOR FARMWORKERS. I
JUST WANTED TO JUST GET YOUR
SENTIMENT ON THAT BECAUSE
THERE'S AN ISSUE CERTAINLY OF
TRUST AND KIND OF WHAT YOU'RE
THINKING IS ABOUT THAT WITH I
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S A 100%
ACCURATE I WASN'T THERE BUT
CERTAINLY THE PEOPLE IN THE
STUDY IS A PRETTY CREDIBLE AND
I JUST WANTED TO GET YOUR SENSE
OF. YOUR THINKING ABOUT HOW THE
FARM WORKERS ARE BEING TREATED
AND WHETHER YOU HAVE. ANY PLANS
WITH IN THAT REGARD. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION AND I
APOLOGIZE IT- I HAD TROUBLE
HEARING THE ENTIRE QUESTION BUT
I THINK I HAVE A GENERAL SENSE
OF. WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
OKAY- YOU KNOW. I THE
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY I COME
FROM- LAKE COUNTY- CALIFORNIA
RURAL AREA IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND- I WAS VERY MUCH
AN AGRICULTURAL DISTRICT
DISTRICT AND SO- I CERTAINLY
RECOGNIZE- ALL OF THE- MANY
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE- WITH
AGRICULTURAL AND- ENSURING THAT
OUR AGRICULTURAL WORKERS ARE-
ARE. HEALTHY AND SAFE IN THE
WORKPLACE- THAT'S REGARDLESS OF
IF THERE'S A PANDEMIC OR NOT-
AND- AND WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO IN THAT REALM IN TERMS OF
EDUCATING EMPLOYERS- EDUCATING
WORKERS AND REALLY TRYING TO
GET AT- HOW TO BEST REACH THEM.
RIGHT BECAUSE THERE IS A LACK
OF TRUST HI I'M- I. I I'M NOT
SURE I WOULD GO SO FAR AS TO
SAY IT'S A LACK OF TRUST AND
HELLO SHOULD BUT- BUT PROBABLY
MORE A LACK OF TRUST IN
GOVERNMENT- SERVICE OR- YOU
KNOW SORT OF THE REPRESENTATIVE
GOVERNMENT. AND. AND IT. ITS
ACT YOU KNOW IT'S ALWAYS. I'D
TO FIND NEW AND INNOVATIVE WAYS
TO REACH THEM AND- YOU KNOW I'M
VERY- I'VE BEEN VERY- EXCITED
ACTUALLY ABOUT ALL OF THE GREAT
IDEAS COMING FROM NOT ONLY FROM
THE D. I. R. STAFF FROM THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
HOLLOW SHAFT. DIVISION WORKERS
COMP BUT ALSO- OUT WE WORK
CLOSELY WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION WITH THE
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS
BOARD- OUR LABOR AGENCY OF
COURSE- AND ANOTHER A NUMBER OF
OTHER STATE AGENCIES AND REALLY
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS- NAG IN
PARTICULAR. AROUND HOW HOW DO
WE BEST REACH- OUR MOST
VULNERABLE WORKERS- AGRICULTURE
BEING A VERY- AT HIGH ON THAT
LIST PARTICULARLY- DURING THE
WILDFIRE SEASON THIS YOU KNOW
WHICH- UNFORTUNATELY HAS
BECOME. ALL YEAR ALMOST THAT
YOUKNOW HOW DO WE PROTECT
THEM- I ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
THE EQUIPMENT THAT THEY NEED
THE PROTECTIONS THAT THEY NEED.
AND WE HAVE DONE US A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF WORK- IN
THIS AREA OUR REGION EDUCATION.
BUT WE HAVE MORE PLANNED- ALL
DESPITE A COUPLE OF- WHAT I
THOUGHT WAS VERY AT CREATIVE
APPROACH WE RENTED OUT A MOBILE
TRUCK- MOBILE BILLBOARDS- IT
BACK IN NOVEMBER AND DECEMBER
IN OUR LABOR COMMISSIONER
LILLIAN. BROWN GARCIA ACTUALLY
WENT DOWN AND- PARTICIPATED IN
SOME OF THE OUTREACH EVENTS IN
THE COACHELLA REGION. I'M AND-
THE MOBILE BILLBOARDS- WE'RE IN
ENGLISH AND SPANISH I AND
THERE'S SORT OF A CARAVAN OF-
FOLKS THAT WENT FROM ONE
AGRICULTURAL WORK SITE TO
ANOTHER- ALONG WITH COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT WE ARE
PARTNERING WITH. AND I THINK
THAT'S REALLY KEY IN REACHING-
MANY ARE FAR VULNERABLE
WORKERS. IS GOING. TO THOSE-
COMMUNITY BASED OR INCISIONS
THE WHO FOLKS TRUST RIGHT-
WORST MAYBE I KNOW- BUT A MAN
OF THESE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE ARE WELL
KNOWN AND TRUSTED- AND WHAT WE
DID BACK IN BOB- LATE LAST YEAR
WAS I'M JUST EDUCATE
FARMWORKERS ON THEIR RIGHTS-
THIS WAS ON THE HEELS OF-
HAVING HAD REPORTS. THAT THEY
WERE SUFFERING RETALIATION-
INCLUDING- ILLEGAL DISMISSAL
FOR REQUESTING PAID SICK LEAVE-
AND SO THIS WAS A VERY-
TARGETED- OUTREACH ACTIVITY- IN
IT WHERE WE DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH
INFORMATION TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION ON SOME OF THE-
COMPLAINTS COMING TO US BUT- WE
FELT WE REALLY NEEDED TO TAKE-
MAKE A GESTURE EIGHT GRAND
GESTURE IF YOU WILL- TO LET
THEM KNOW THAT- THANK YOU FOR
THAT RIGHT. I APPRECIATE I JUST
I RAISE THAT BECAUSE A NUMBER
OF OUR COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE. CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT FARMWORKERS IMAGES WE
JUST ASK ON THEIR BEHALF I
THINK IN ADDITION TO MY OWN- TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOUR DEBT
REMAINS A PRIORITY AND THERE'S
A SENSITIVITY THERE. JUST A
LITTLE BIT IN EARLY NOVEMBER
HELLO SHE RECEIVED AS STE AS OF
HER NOVEMBER SEVEN THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TWELVE.
COLBERT NINETEEN RELATED
COMPLAINTS CONDUCTED ONE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN COLD RELATED INSPECTIONS
AND ISSUED ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN CITATIONS AT FORTY TWO
LOCATIONS. A HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN CITATIONS ARE SEVEN
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
TWELVE COMPLAINTS. IS THERE IS
A RATE OF ONE POINT FIVE
PERCENT. HE DID M. I. QUESTION
HAS TO DO WITH CONFIDENCE IN
EMPLOYEES IN YOUR KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT THESE INVESTIGATIONS OF
THESE THINGS THAT YOU'VE
GENERALLY REVIEWED DURING YOUR
TEN YEAR- IT AND HAVE A
CONFIDENCE THAT THESE THINGS
WERE CONDUCTED IT AT THIS LEVEL
BECAUSE OF A ONE POINT FIVE
PERCENT. RATE OF- COMPLAINT
SORTATION SEEMS TO JUST GENERAL
STATUS PRETTY LOW. SHE WANTED
TO DRAW THE YOUR TEN TO GET
YOUR THOUGHTS THAT AND SEE IF
YOU HAVE BEEN. IN THAT PROCESS
AT ALL. SURE YES THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION AND- YES- WE HAVE
HAD QUITE A BIT OF NEWS
COVERAGE ON- ARE ON THE WAY ON
OUR APPROACH- DURING THE
PANDEMIC TO. TO INVESTIGATING-
PLANS CALL THE OF COURSE BUT-
IN ADDITION TO CODE WE HAVE ON
GOING ON HEALTH AND SAFETY
COMPLAINTS. AND SOME OF THAT
SEEKS TO GIVE YOU UP-
ADDITIONAL PERSPECTIVE ON THIS-
WE HAD- FOUR OVERALL
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS IN TWENTY
TWENTY. WE PROCESSED OVER
ELEVEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
COOL THE NINETEEN COMPLAINTS-
WE CONDUCTED EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
ONSITE INSPECTIONS TO ADDRESS
OVER NINETEEN HAZARDS. AND
ISSUE TWO HUNDRED NINETY SIX
OCCASIONS WHICH AMOUNTED TO
ABOUT TWO POINT THREE MILLION
IN PENALTIES- TO THE END OF THE
YEAR- WE CONDUCTED MORE THAN
THIRTEEN THOUSAND ON SITE
COMPLIANCE ASSISTANCE AND
VISITS WITH BOTH ENFORCEMENT
AND CONSULTATION SERVICES- AND
DIRECTING EMPLOYERS TO CORRECT
HAZARDS IN EDUCATING THEM ON
COULD NINETEEN REQUIREMENTS.
AND DO YOU HAVE A HAS A
PERSONALLY AS THE DIRECTOR DO
YOU HAVE A HIGH LEVEL OF
CONFIDENCE. THAT THAT THAT
LEVEL OF IMPACT THAT IN TERMS
OF WHETHER THE AMOUNT OF THE
FINES AND THE NUMBER OF
CITATIONS THAT ARE ISSUED HAS
BEEN APPROPRIATELY AGGRESSIVE
IN ORDER TO RESPOND TO THE
EMPLOYEES. COMPLAINTS YES I
THINK THAT WE ARE WE HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE INSPECTION
PROCESS AND- WE THE WAY WE GO
ABOUT- CONDUCTING OUR
INVESTIGATIONS I THINK IS. ONE
THAT- ARE REALLY FORCES
EMPLOYERS TO TAKE CORRECTIVE
ACTION AND THERE THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR REMEDIATION
IT'S NOT WE AREN'T ONE OF. AN
ENTITY THAT NECESSARILY WALKS
IN AND HANDS SOMEONE A CITATION
AND WALKS OUT RIGHT LIKE OUR
APPROACH IS TO HELP THE
EMPLOYER. BOB GAIN COMPLIANCE
AND WE GIVE THEM LOTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES REMEDIATE THAT.
THAT SAID WHAT I LIKE TO HAVE-
YOU KNOW. WHAT I LIKE TO HAVE
FIVE TIMES THE AMOUNT OF
INSPECTORS OUT THERE- OF COURSE
YOU KNOW IN A PANDEMIC- WE ALL
WORRY ABOUT WHAT WHAT YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT WE'RE NOT DOING OR OR
WHAT WE'RE NOT ADDRESSING. BUT
I DO BELIEVE THAT THE-
INSPECTORS THAT WE HAVE- WE'VE
BEEN AUTHORIZED ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES- WE HAVE BEEN FOCUSED
ON FILLING A LARGE NUMBER OF
VACANCIES THAT EXIST. AND I
THINK ONCE OF THOSE VACANCIES
ARE FILLED- WE CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS
THANK THANK YOU TO THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THAT- THAT WE
DO HAVE THAT SUFFICIENT STAFF.
YOU KNOW A LOT OF THAT
COMPLAINTS THAT WE RECEIVE OUR-
DON'T REALLY RISE TO THE LEVEL
OF MEETING AN INSPECTION WE
FIND THAT EMPLOYERS WANT TO BE
COMPLIANCE- FOR THE MOST PART.
AND ART THROUGH OUR LETTER
INSPECTION THAT WE SENT A
LETTER INSPECTION FOR EVERY
COMPLAINT THAT THAT WE OPEN-
INVESTIGATION AND WE OPEN AND
FOR THE LARGE MAJORITY OF
THOSE. THEY ADDRESS AND
REMEDIATE THE ISSUE THAT- COME
TO OUR ATTENTION IT'S THE ONES
WHERE WE- ARE MORE EGREGIOUS-
WHERE THERE MAY BE AN OUTBREAK
WHERE WE- STRATEGICALLY SEND
OUR OUR INSPECTORS. I SEE THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MR MAJORITY LEADER- HE STARTED
DOWN A LIST OF QUESTIONS- SO
THAT WAS REALLY HELPFUL I WOULD
JUST ASK IN TERMS OF THOSE
BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS FROM
TWENTY TWENTY ONE OBVIOUSLY-
IT'S BEEN A DIFFICULT YEAR.
HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO FEEL A
NUMBER OF THOSE POSITIONS THAT
YOU NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO CATCH
UP ON THE. BACKLOG AND COATED.
YES YES WE- WE RESULT HAVE A
BACKLOG EXISTING BACKLOG BUT WE
INTO YOUR QUESTION HAVE WE MADE
PROGRESS PROGRESS. WE MOST
DEFINITELY HAVE- WE HAVE- HIRED
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY I BELIEVE
YES FILLED THIRTY- OF OUR
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL I'M AS
WELL SEVEN- HE LEADERSHIP
POSITIONS THROUGHOUT THE STATE-
IN RECENT MONTHS- WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY- FORTY FOUR
ENFORCEMENT POSITIONS THAT
REMAIN TO BE FILLED.
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAD OUR
REACHED OUT TO OUR SISTER
AGENCIES THAT HAVE- AT A SAFETY
ENGINEERS THAT PREVIOUSLY HAD
WORKED AT CAL OSHA- AND THE
LOAN TO THE STAFF BACK TO US-
FOR APPEAR AN INTERIM PERIOD OF
TIME- TO HELP US YOU KNOW WE
SORT OF GET. MORE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND AND- THE LEADERSHIP THAT
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
INSPECTORS THEMSELVES HAVE BEEN
TREMENDOUS THEY'VE EXTENDED
THEIR TIME TWICE NOW TO
CONTINUE. B. THE WORK OUR WHILE
WE CONTINUE TO GET STAFFED UP-
IN CALLOW SAID I JUST WANTED TO
POINT OUT ONE THING SINCE-
SINCE IF I POINTED OUT IN MY
QUESTIONS AND ANSWERS A FEW
MONTHS AGO- THAT WE HAD- HIRED
MORE STAFF IN DIR IN NOT JUST
TELEVISION BUT IN DIR- YOU KNOW
WE HAD- FANS SIGNIFICANT GAINS-
FILE IN THE LAST MONTH. AND
WE'VE CONTINUED TO FIVE. MAKE
GAINES I MENTIONED PROXIMALLY
TWO HUNDRED HIRES IN EIGHT
MONTHS IN THE LAST THREE MONTHS
SINCE THE- SENDING MY
RESPONSES. WE'VE HIRED BY TWO
HUNDRED MORE STAFF SO WE ARE
STEADILY MAKING PROGRESS I HAVE
I WOULD IT'S A VERY
CHALLENGING- THAT TIME RIGHT
NOW TO BE RECRUITING INDUSTRIAL
HYGIENIST AND SAFETY ENGINEERS
BUT SO FAR WE HAVE FOUND I'M
VERY HIGH QUALITY CANDIDATES WE
HOPE TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
I'M AND WE ARE MAKING GAINS IN-
OUR HIRING PROCESS. I WOULD
BECAUSE YOU MAY KNOW WE LOST
OUR HIRING AUTHORITY- SOMETIME
AGO AND WERE IN THE PARK
PROCESS OF REGAINING THAT
HIRING IS THIRTY WHICH WE
BELIEVE WILL HELP EXPEDITE OUR
HIRING PROCESS ITSELF. GOT IT-
I WANT OTHER UNRELATED QUESTION
BUT- IT BECAUSE. OF COBIT
OBVIOUSLY WORK AT AND THIS IS
WORK REN'T TO FOR WAGED A LOT.
AND TYPICALLY MEN OF THOSE GO
TO ONE OF YOUR REGIONAL OFFICES
I GUESS I WOULD ASK HAVE YOU
NOTICED- FEWER WAGE CLAIMS
BECAUSE OF THAT THAT ISSUE OF
REGIONAL OFFICES JUST CURIOUS.
I'M NO WE HAVE NOT ACTUALLY-
THE- I'VE TALKED TO OUR LABOR
COMMISSIONER ABOUT THIS A
COUPLE OF TIMES AND- THEY
INDICATE THAT THE NUMBERS ARE
ABOUT THE SAME- AS THEY HAVE
BEEN. FREED PANDEMIC. WE TO
YOUR POINT OF ACCESSIBILITY TO-
TO STAFF WE DO- IF FOLKS. I
HEARD THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER SCHEME COMES INTO
THE OFFICE- WHEN NEEDED TO OUT
TO MEET WITH FOLKS. BUT DOT
ADDING TO THAT ACCESSIBILITY
ISSUES WE ARE ENGAGED IN A- OF
THE PROCESS OF PUTTING AN
ONLINE WAGE CLAIM FIVE
APPLICATIONS TOGETHER FOR OUR
WEBSITE WE HAVE ONE FOR
RETALIATION- COMPLAINTS- AND I
ACTUALLY WORD LEVERAGING D. S.
B. ONE FIFTEEN FUNDING FOR
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITY- TO ALLOW
US TO PUT OUR WAGE CLAIM
PROCESS ONLINE. GRAD SO WE'RE
WORKING WITH CDT ON EXPEDITING
THAT AND WE HOPE TO HAVE- A
WAGE CLAIM PROCESS THAT WILL
AGAIN IMPROVE ACCESS FOR
FARMWORKERS. DIRECTOR THANK
YOU- I'M GONNA GO TO SENATOR
LAWYER WHO HAS THOUGHT OF A
QUESTION. I'M SORRY. IT WILL
JUST EXCHANGE INFORMATION
AFTERWARDS BUT- I DID A BILL
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY.
THAT REQUIRED PREVAIL WAGE
SCOFFLAWS. TO BE REPORTED ON
THE INTERNET AND IT WAS
DISCONTINUED DURING THE SORTS
**** MINISTRATION ARE BUT IT
WAS DONE DURING THE DAVIS
ADMINISTRATION AND I SHOULD
JUST TALK TO YOU ABOUT WHETHER.
THERE'S AN AVENUE OF
RESUSCITATING MATTER WHETHER IT
WAS WHETHER IT WAS CONSIDERED
AND IT ONLY CAME UP- CROSSED MY
MIND IN HEARING THE PROTONS
QUESTION S LET'S JUST TALK
ABOUT THAT OFFLINE BUT- I WANT
TO PUT THAT ON YOUR RADAR
SCREEN. THANK YOU US SENATOR-
IF NO OTHER QUESTIONS WE-
DIRECTOR OR GOING TO GO TO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC. WHO
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF FIRST AND WE'RE GONNA START
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE ONE AND- I'M
ACTUALLY NOT SEEING ANYONE STEP
FORWARD SO WE WILL GO TO OUR
BACKUP ROOM ROOM ONE TWELVE OR
WE MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR THE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO BE
HERE AND- I. PARTICIPATE WITH
SOCIAL DISTANCING. I SEE NO ONE
IN ROOM ONE TWELVE STEPPING
FORWARD. SO I'M GONNA INTRODUCE
OURSELVES TO THE MODERATOR WHO
IS STANDING BY. AND SAY WELCOME
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE FOR MEMBERS IN
SUPPORT- LET ME ASK IF THE
MODERATOR IS THERE. YES THANK
YOU THANK YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU AN S. YOUR Q. AND
PEOPLE LOVE MADAME MODERATOR- I
WANT TO SAY TO THE WITNESSES
WHO WERE IN THE QUEUE. WE ASK
THAT WHEN YOU SPEAK PLEASE
PROVIDE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION IF ANY AND
POSITION ON THE APPOINTMENT AND
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF OUR
STENOGRAPHER PLEASE SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. MADE A
MODERATOR YOU WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND OPEN THE LINES FOR SUPPORT
WITNESSES. THANK YOU RIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DRIVING GREAT WHILE LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WITH UFCW WESTERN
STATE COUNCIL UPW STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE REAPPOINTMENT
ACTUALLY HAGEN AS DIRECTOR OF
THE AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS IF YOU W. REPRESENTS
ROUGHLY A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
ALMOST ALL OF WHOM ARE FROM
NINE UNTIL WORKERS AND HAVE
BEEN BUILDING CALIFORNIANS
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC. I DROPPED HAGEN
HARDLY DO CAREER AND STATE FARM
SERVING FOR THAT THROUGHOUT THE
CAN DOWN SHE HAS BEEN A ADDED
FOR WORK AND FIGHTING FOR THEIR
RIGHT TO A STATE AND HEALTHY
WORKPLACE DIRECTOR HAGEN HAS
DEFENDED CALIFORNIA THE WORKERS
WORKPLACE RIGHT. CALIFORNIANS
WORKER STATE FARM THE JOB
PROTECTED CALIFORNIA'S MOST
INJURED WORKERS AND I
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY. W. STRONGLY SUPPORTS
DIRECTOR HAGEN REAPPOINTMENT TO
BE I. R. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH HER TO
ENSURE OUR MEMBERS ARE
PROTECTED DURING. AFTER THAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU MUCH NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU I A LOT FOR RISING
ISSUE AT THE TIME OKAY THING
YOU MADAM MODERATOR WILL BE
BACK WITH YOU A AND A FEW
MINUTES. I'M GONNA- COME BACK
INTO ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT
MIGHT BE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION I CAN ALREADY TELL
THERE IS NO ONE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE I WILL LOOK
AGAIN IN ROOM ONE TWELVE. AGAIN
THE SEEING NO ONE APPROACH THE
DYESS- MATAMATA RAIDER I'M
COMING BACK TO YOU SOONER THAN
ANTICIPATED OR OTHER
INDIVIDUALS IN THE QUEUE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO LINES THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. WELL WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY MADAM
MODERATOR- I APPRECIATE VERY
MUCH I WILL COME BACK. HERE AND
IT DIRECTOR LET ME JUST ASSURE
YOU IT DOESN'T ALWAYS GO SO
EASILY SO. LET ME COME BACK AND
I I'M SEEIN- C. ONLINE MOVE IT
TO THE LIGHT ARE WOULD MOVE THE
NOMINATION THANK YOU A MOTION
BY SENATOR LAYERED- MADAM
SECRETARY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS PLEASE
TURN ON YOUR MIKE'S. HE
HERTZBERG HI IT'S PROVIDE
GROWTH HI I LAYERED HI I HAD
CAN A CONCERN ORDERS DIRECTOR
FOR TWO ZERO CONGRATULATIONS
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY THANK YOU SO MUCH THANKS
FOR HAVING ME. OUR COLLEAGUES I
ENJOY THIS- WE ARE AMAZED. DONE
FOR THE DAY. SO LET ME SEE IT
NEXT WEEK WE WILL HAVE-
EXECUTIVE SESSION AND WE WILL
HAVE THE CARRY OVER FROM THIS
WEEK I BELIEVE ALL CONFIRM THAT
WITH STAFF AGAIN LET ME SAY
WELCOME BACK TO SENATOR GROWTH.
AND WITH F. THE RULES COMMITTEE
IS ADJOURNED.